last time we started discussing graphed
limits and let me remind you some of the
notions and definitions that were
involved
one of the main objects in graph limits
is that of a graph on which are
symmetric measurable functions from the
Union Square to that unit interval so
here symmetric means that W of x comma y
equals to W of Y comma X we define a
notion of convergence for a sequence of
graphics
I remember the notion of convergence is
that a sequence is convergent if the
sequence of homomorphism densities
converges as n goes to infinity for
every fixed F every fixed graph so this
is how we define convergence so sequence
of graphs or graphs they converge if all
the homomorphism densities so you should
think of this as sub graph statistics if
all of these statistics converge we also
say that a sequence converges to a
particular limit if these homomorphism
densities converge to the corresponding
homomorphism density of the limit for
every ok so this is how we define
convergence we also define this notion
of a
distance and to do that we first define
the cut norm to be the following
quantity defined by taking two subsets s
and T which are measurable everything so
far it's going to be measurable and look
at what is the maximum possible
deviation of the integral of this
function on this box X cross T and here
W you should think of it as taking real
values allowing both positive and
negative values because otherwise you
should just take s and here to be the
whole interval okay and this definition
was motivated by our discussion of
discrepancy coming from quasi randomness
now if I give you two graphs or griffons
and ask you to compare them you are
allowed to permute the vertices in some
sense so to find the best overlay and
and that notion is captured in the
definition of cut distance which is
defined to be the following quantity
where we consider over all possible
measure preserving by directions from
the interval to itself of the difference
between these two griffons if I rotate
one of them using this measure
preserving bisection so think of this as
permuting the vertices
[Applause]
so these were the definitions that were
involved last time and at the end of
last lecture I stated three main
theorems of graph limit theory so I
forgot to mention how what are some of
the histories of this this theory so
there were a number of important papers
that developed this very idea of graph
limits which is actually somewhat if you
think about anything all of
combinatorics we like to deal with
discrete objects and even the idea of
taking a limit is rather novel so this
work is due to you know a number of
people in particular last Oh lavas
played a very important central role in
the development of this theory and
various people came to this theory from
different perspectives some from more
pure perspectives and some form or
applied perspectives and this theory is
now getting used in more and more places
including you know statistics machine
learning and so on and I'll explain
where that comes up just a little bit at
the end of last lecture I stated three
main theorems and what I want to do
today is develop some tools so that we
can prove those theorems in the next
lecture I won't develop some tools in
particular you will see some of the
things that we've talked about in the
chapter on similarities regularity lemma
come up again in a slightly different
language so much of what I will say
today hopefully should already be
familiar to you but you will see it
again from the perspective of graph
limits but first before telling you
about the tools I want to give you some
more examples so one of the ways that
motivated graph limits last time is this
example of a erdos-renyi random graph or
sequence of quasi random graphs
converging to a constant but the
constant graph on is the limit but
whatever generalizations
what about generalizations of that
construction when your limit is not the
constant so this leads to this idea of a
W
random graph which generalizes that of
an erdos-renyi random graph
so in address 20 we're looking at every
edge occurring with the same probability
P uniform throughout the graph but what
I want to do now is allow you to change
the edge probability somewhat and a
special case of this so before giving
you the more general definition a
special case of this is an important
model of random graphs known as the
stochastic block model in particular a
two-block model consists of the
following data where I'm looking at two
types of vertices let's call them red
and blue where the vertices are assigned
the colors and random for example 5050
but any other probability is fine and
now I put down the edges according to
which colors the two endpoints are so
two red vertices are joined with edge
probability P or R if I haven't red and
blue then I may have a different
probability joining them and likewise
with blue blue like that so in other
words I can encode this probability
information in a matrix
like that way to diagnose oh it's
symmetric across the diagonal okay so
this is a slightly more general version
of this rainy random graph where now I
have potentially different types of
vertices and you can Maginot these kinds
of models are very importantly applied
mathematics for modeling certain
situations such as for example if you
have you know people with different
political party affiliations how likely
are they to talk to each other so you
can imagine you're some of these numbers
might be bigger than others and you know
there's an important statistical problem
if I give you a graph can you cluster or
classify the vertices according to their
types if I do not show you in advance
what the colors are but should show you
what the output graph is so these are
important statistical questions worth
lots of applications this is an example
of if you have only two blocks but of
course you can have more than two blocks
and the graphing context tells us that
we should not limit ourselves to just
blocks right if I give you any graph on
W I can also construct a random graph so
what I would like to do is to consider
the following construction where okay so
this is called W random graph denoted by
G and W where I formed a graph using the
following process first the vertex set
is labeled by 1 through N and let me
draw the vertex types by taking uniform
random X 1 to xn a uniform iid so these
are you think of them as the vertex
colors the vertex types and I put an
edge between
I and J with probability exactly W of X
I XJ so for all I less than J
independently that's the definition of a
W random graph and the two-block
stochastic model is a special case of
this doubly random graph for the graph
on which corresponds to this red blue
picture here so the generation process
would be I give you some X 1 X 2 X 3 and
then likewise X 1 X 3 X 2 and then I
evaluate what is the value of this
graphing at at these points
and those are my edge probabilities so
what I described it's a special case of
this general W random graph any
questions so like before an important
statistical question is if I show you
the graph can you tell me a good model
for where this graph came from so that's
something that it's one of the reasons
why people in applied math might care
about these types of constructions but
for us let me talk about some theorems
I've told you that the sequence of air -
ranee random graphs converges to the
constant graph on P so instead of taking
a constant graph on P now I start with W
random graph and you should expect and
it is indeed true that this sequence
converges to W limit let W be a graph on
and for each n let me draw this graph G
sub n using the W random graph model
independently then with probability 1
the sequence converges to the graph on W
ok so in the sense that I've shown above
described above so the statement tells
us couple of things one that W random
graphs converge to the limit W as you
should expect and two that every graph
every graph on W is the limit point of
some sequence of graphs right so this is
something that we never quite explicitly
stated before so let me make this this
remark
so in particular every W is the limit of
some sequence of graphs just like every
real number in analogy to what we said
last time every real number is the limit
of a sequence of rational numbers
through rational approximation and this
is some form of approximation by
graphing by a sequence of graphs okay so
I'm not going to prove this theorem
the proof is it's not difficult so it
using that definition of subgraph
convergence or the proof uses what's
known as the Zuma's inequality so by an
appropriate application of Zuma's
inequality on the concentration of
martingales one can improve one can
prove this theorem here by estimating
the probability that so show that to
show that the probability that the f
density in GN it is very close to the f
density w with high probability okay any
questions so far so this is an important
example of you know one of the
motivations of graph limits but now
let's get back to when I said earlier
that I would like to develop a sequence
of tools that will allow us to prove the
main theorem stated at the end of the
last lecture and this will sound very
familiar because we're going to write
down some lemma that we did back in the
chapter of some released regularity
lemma but now in the language of
griffons so first there's a counting
level
the goal of the counting lemon is to
show that if you have two griffons
which are close to each other in the
sense of cut distance then there F
densities are similar to each other so
here's a statement W and you graph ohms
then the earth density of W minus the F
density of U their difference is no more
than a constant to a number of edges of
F times the cut distance between u and W
okay so maybe some of you already see
how to do this from our discussion on
similarity regularity lemma the any case
I want to just rewrite the proof again
in the language of griffons and this
will hopefully so we did two proofs of
the triangle counting lemma 1 was
hopefully more intuitive for you which
is you pick a typical vertex has lots of
neighbors on both sides and therefore
lots of edges in between and then there
was a second proof which I said was a
more analytic proof where you took out
one edge at a time and that proof
I think it's technically easier to
implement especially for general H but
the first time you see it you might not
quite see you know what the calculation
was about so I want to do this exact
same calculation again in the language
of griffons and hopefully it should be
clear this time yeah so this is the same
as the counting lemma over epsilon
regular pairs so it suffices to prove
the inequality where the right hand side
is replaced not by the cut distance but
by the cut norm and the reason is that
once you have the second inequality by
taking an infimum over all major
preserving by actions feet I noticed
that that quality does not that change
does not affect the F density by taking
an infimum over feet you recover the
first inequality I want to give you a
small reformulation of the cut norm that
will be useful for thinking about this
counting lemma
here's a reformulation of a cut norm
namely that I can define the cut norm so
here W is taking real values not
necessarily now negative so the cut norm
we saw earlier is defined to be the
supremum over all measurable subsets of
the 0-1 interval of this integral in
absolute value but it turns out I can
rewrite this supremum over a slightly
larger set of objects instead of just
looking over subsets of measurable
instead of just looking over measurable
subsets of the interval
let me now look at measurable functions
but on you and so let me look at
functions yeah so U and V from 0 1 to 0
1 and as always everything is measurable
of the following
integral okay so I claim this is the
this is true that's why I consider this
integral where instead of integrating
over a box now I'm integrating this
expression okay so why is this true well
one of the directions is easy to see
because the right hand side is strictly
an enlargement of the left hand side
alright so by taking you to be the
indicator function of s and need to be
the indicator function of T you see that
the right hand side in fact includes the
left hand side in terms of what you are
allowed to do but what about the other
direction so for the other direction the
main thing is to notice that the
integral or the integrand what's inside
this integral is bilinear in the values
of U and V so in particular the extrema
of this integral as you allow to vary U
and V they are obtained so they are
attained for W for u and V taking values
in the endpoints 0 comma 1 they may be
helpful to think about a discrete
setting when instead of this integral
you have a matrix and two vectors
multiplied from left and right and you
had to decide you know what are the
coordinates of those vectors
it's a bilinear form how do you maximize
or minimize it have to change every
entry to one of its two endpoints
otherwise it can never be
you never loose by doing that okay so
think about it right so this is not
difficult once you see it the right way
but now we have this cut norm expressed
over not set but over bounded functions
and now I'm ready to prove the counting
lemma and instead of writing down the
whole proof for general H let me write
down the calculation that illustrating
it that illustrates this proof for
triangles and the general proof is the
same once you understand how this
argument works and the argument works by
considering the difference between these
two F densities and what I want to do is
so this is some integral right so this
is this integral which I'll write out
so we would like to show that this
quantity here is small if u and W are
closing cut norm so let's write this
integral as a telescoping sum where the
first term is obtained by so by this I
mean W of X comma Y minus U of X comma Y
and then the second term of the
telescoping sum so I you see what
happens I change one factor at a time
and finally I change the third factor
okay so this is an identity if you
expand out all of these differences you
see that everything intermediate cancels
out so it's a telescoping sum but now I
want to show that each term is small how
can I show that each term is small look
at this expression here I claim that for
a fixed value of Z okay so imagine
fixing Z and let x and y vary in this
integral it has the form up there if you
fix Z then you have this U and V coming
from these two factors and they're both
bounded between 0 and 1 so for a fixed
value of Z this is at most W - you cut
norm difference between W and you in
absolute value so if I let Z vary it is
still pounding absolute value by that
quantity so therefore each yes bounded
by W - you cut norm in absolute value
and all three of them together we find
that the whole thing is bounding
absolute value by 3 times the
cut norm difference okay and that
finishes the proof of the candy mama for
triangles of course if you have general
h then you just have more terms you do
you have a longer telescoping sum okay
and you have this down okay so this is a
counting lemma and the claim is exactly
the same proof as the second proof of
the county no matter we did when we
discussed some reduced regularity lemma
and it's counting lemma any questions
yeah
okay let me answer that in a second
first this should be H F okay so your
question was up there
why wasn't sufficient to prove this
version instead of that version it's not
the question okay suppose you I prove it
for this version so I know it this is
true now I take infimum of both sides so
now I consider infimum on both sides so
then this is it's true right because
it's true for every fee but the
left-hand side doesn't change because
the f density in a relabeling of the
vertices it's still it's still the same
quantity whereas this one here is now
that alright
what we see as a corollary of this
country lemma is that if you are a
Cauchy sequence with respect to the cut
distance then the sequence is
automatically convergent you call the
definition of convergence convergence
has to do with F densities converging
and if you have a Cauchy sequence then
the F densities converge and also
related but different statement is that
if you have a sequence WN that converges
to W in cut distance then it implies
that W n converges to W in a sense as
defined for F densities so this cut norm
so qualitatively what the counting lemma
says is that the cut norm is stronger
than the notion of convergence coming
from sub graph densities okay so this is
one part of this regularity method right
so the county lemma
because the other part is the regularity
lemma itself so that's the next thing
we'll do and it turns out that we
actually don't need a full strength of
the regularity lemma we only need
something called a weak regularity lemma
what the week regularity lemma says is I
mean you still have a partition of the
vertices so let me now stated for graph
ons so for a partition P so I have a
partition of the vertex set and a
symmetric measurable function W I'm just
going to admit the word measurable from
now on everything will be measurable
what I can do is okay all of these
assets are also measurable I can define
what's known as a stepping operator that
sends W to this object W sub P obtained
by averaging over the steps SI cross SJ
and replacing that graph on by its
average over each step precisely
so I obtain a new graph on a new
symmetric measurable function W sub P
where the value on X comma Y is defined
to be the following quantity
if X comma white lies in as I cross s J
so pictorially what happens is that you
look at your graph on there's a
partition of the vertex set so to speak
the interval doesn't have to be a
partition in two intervals before
illustrations posted no it looks like
that and what I do is I take this w and
I replace it by a new graph on a new
symmetric measurable function W so P
obtained by averaging take each box
replace it by its average put the
average into the box so this is what W
star P they're supposed to be just a few
minor technicalities if if this
denominator is equal to zero let's
ignore the set I mean then then you have
a zero major set anyways so we we
ignored that set so everything will be
treated up to measure zero changing the
function on measure zero sets so it
doesn't really matter if you're not
strictly allowed to do this division
okay so this operator plays an important
role in the regularity lemma because
it's how we think about partitioning
what happens to a graph under
partitioning it has several other names
if you look at it from slightly
different perspectives so you can view
it as a projection in the sense of a
Hilbert in the sense of Hilbert space so
in the Hilbert space of functions
on the unit square the stepping operator
is a projection onto the subspace of
constants subspace of functions that are
constant on each step so that's one
interpretation another interpretation is
that this operation is also a
conditional expectation if you know what
a conditional expectation actually is in
the sense of probability theory then so
then that's what happens here if you
view 0 1 squared as a probability space
then what we're doing is we're doing
conditional expectation relative to the
sigma-algebra
generated by these steps ok so these are
just couple ways of thinking about
what's going on they might be somewhat
helpful later on if you're familiar with
these notions but if you're not don't
worry about it concretely it's what
happens up there ok so now let me state
the week regularity lemma
okay so the week regularity lemma is
attributed to freeze and canon oboe
their work predates the language of
graphics so it's stated in the language
of graphs but it's the same proof so let
me state it for you both in terms of
graphs and in graphs what it says is
that for every epsilon and every graph
on W there exists a partition they noted
P of 0 1 interval and now I tell you how
many sets they are so it's a partition
into so not a tower type number of parts
but only roughly an exponential number
of parts for to the one over epsilon
squared measurable sets such that if we
apply the stepping operator to this
graph on we obtain an approximation of
the graph on in the cut norm so that's
the statement of the week regularity
lemma there exist a partition such that
if you do this stepping then you obtain
an approximation so I want you to think
about what this has to do with the usual
version of somewhere this regularity
lemma that you seen earlier
so hopefully you should realize morally
they're about the same types of
statements and not more important how
are they different from each other and
now let me state a version for graphs
all right so which is similar but not
exactly the same as what we've what we
just saw for graph ons so it's ok so let
me let me state it so for graphs
the week regularity lemma says that okay
so so for craft so let me define a
partition P of the vertex set is called
weekly epsilon regular if the following
is true if it is the case that whenever
I look at two vertex
sub sets a and B of the vertex set of G
then the number of vertices between a
and B is what you should expect based on
the density information that comes out
of this partition namely if I sum over
all the parts of the partition look at
how many vertices from a lie in the
corresponding parts and then multiply by
the edge density between these parts
so that's your predicted value based on
the data that comes out of the partition
so claim that this is the actual number
of edges this is the predicted number of
edges and those two numbers should be
similar to each other by most epsilon
and where n is the number of vertices so
this is the definition of what it means
for a partition to be weakly epsilon
regular okay so it's important to think
about why this is weaker it's called
weak right so why is a weaker than the
notion of epsilon regularity so why is
it weaker so previously we had epsilon
regular partition in
definition of similarities regularity
lemma is Absalon regular partition and
here notion of a weekly epsilon regular
so why is this a lot weaker it is not
saying that individual pairs of parts
are epsilon regular and eventually we're
going to have this number of parts so
our state a theorem in a second so these
sizes of the parts are much smaller than
epsilon fraction but what this weak
notion of regularity says if you look at
it globally right so not looking at
specific parts but looking at it
globally then this partition is a good
approximation of what's going on in the
actual graph okay so it's worth thinking
about it's really worth thinking about
what's the difference between this weak
notion and the usual notion but first
let me state this regularity lemma so
the weak regularity lemma for graphs
says that for every epsilon and every
graph G there exists a weekly epsilon
regular partition of the vertex set of G
into at most four to the one over
epsilon squared parts
now you might wonder why we why did
freezing current come up with this
notion of regularity
it's a weaker result if you don't care
about the bounds because a epsilon
regular partition will be automatically
weakly epsilon regular okay so maybe
with small changes of epsilon if you
wish but but basically this this is a
weaker notion compared to what we had
before but of course the advantage is
that you have a much more reasonable
number of parts right it's not a power
it's just a single exponential and this
is important and their motivation was a
computer science and algorithm
application so I want to take a brief
detour and mention mention why you might
care about epsilon weakly epsilon
regular partitions in particular the
problem that is of interest is in
approximating something called a max cut
so the max cut prom asks you to
determine given a graph G find the
maximum over all subsets of vertices the
maximum number of vertices between a set
and its complement that's called a cut I
give you a graph and I want to know find
this s so that do you can have as many
edges across this set as possible this
is an important problem in computer
science extremely important problem and
the status of this problem is that it is
known to be difficult to get it you know
even within 1% so the best algorithm is
due to comments and Williams
so important algorithm that was one of
the foundational algorithms in
semi-definite programming so agree dated
word semi definite programming came up
or during this course when we discussed
growth index inequality so they came up
with an approximation algorithm so here
I'm only talking about polynomial time
so efficient algorithms approximation
algorithm with approximation ratio
around point a seven eight so one can
obtain a cut that is within basically
thirteen percent of the maximum okay so
it's an approximation algorithm however
it is known that it is hard in the sense
of complexity theory like np-hard to
approximate beyond the ratio 16 / 17
which is around point four nine one and
there is an important conjecturing
computer science called a unique games
conjecture that if that conjecture were
true then it would be difficult it will
be also and be hard to approximate but
young the Romans Williamson ratio and so
this indicates the status of this from
there it is difficult to do an epsilon
approximation but if the graph I give
you is dense
tense now meaning a quadratic number of
edges where n is the number of vertices
then it turns out that the regularity
type algorithms right so that theorem
combined with the algorithmic versions
allows you to get polynomial time
approximation algorithms so this is
polynomial time approximation schemes so
one can approximate up to 1 minus
epsilon ratio so you know one can
approximate up to an epsilon N squared
additive error in polynomial time so in
particular if I willing to lose you know
point or 1 and squared then there's an
algorithm to approximate the size of the
maxcut and that algorithm basically
comes from
I mean without giving you any details
whatsoever the algorithm essentially
comes from first finding a regularity
partitioned ok so the partition breaks
this set of vertices into some number of
pieces and now I search over search over
all possible ratios to divide each piece
there is a bounded number of parts each
one in ohms I decide to I cut this up
half half to I cut it up you know
one-third two-thirds and so on and those
numbers alone because of this definition
of weekly epsilon regular once you know
what this intersections of a be is that
say a compliment is what individual sets
then I basically know the number of
edges so I can approximate the size of
the max cut using an epsilon a weekly
epsilon regular partition alright so
that was the motivation for these weekly
epsilon partitions at least the
algorithmic applications any questions
okay so let's take a quick break and
then afterwards I want to show you the
proof of the week regularity lemma
alright so let me start the proof of the
week regularity lemma and the proof is
by this energy increment argument so
let's see what this energy increment
argument looks like in the language of
griffons
so energy now means L - L - energy
increment okay so the statement of this
lemma is that if you have W a graphing
and P a partition 0 comma 1 interval and
such that always measurable pieces I'm
not going to even write it always
measurable pieces and such that the
difference between W and W steps piece
averaged over steps P is bigger than
Epsilon so this is the notion of not
being not epsilon regular
in leader in the weak sense not weekly
epsilon regular then there exists a
refinement P prime of P dividing each
part of P into at most four parts such
that the two norm increases by more than
epsilon squared under this refinement so
should be similar and should be familiar
to you because we have similar arguments
from similarities regularity lemma so
let's see the proof because you have
violation of epsilon weak epsilon
regularity there exists sets s and T
measurable subsets of zero one interval
such that this integral evaluated over s
cross T is more than epsilon in absolute
value so now let me take P prime to be
the common refinement
of pee by introducing soccer by just the
refinement of P by introducing s and T
into this partition
okay so throw s and T in and break
everything according to s and T and so
each part becomes at most four sub parts
so that's the and most four sub parts I
now need to show that half an energy
increment and to do this let me first
perform the following calculation so
remember this symbol here is the inner
product obtained by multiplying and
integrating over the entire box I claim
that that inner product equals to the
inner product between WP + WP prime
because what happens here is we are
looking at a situation where WP prime is
constant on each part so when I do this
in a product I can replace W by is its
average and likewise over here I can
also replace it by its average and you
end up being the same you end up having
the same average and these two averages
are both just what happens if you do
stepping by P you also have that W has
inner product with 1 sub s cross T the
same stat of T prime by the same reason
because over s cross team
so s cross T it's a union of the parts
of P prime union of hearts okay so let's
see with those observations you find
that okay so this is true just from the
first equality so now let me draw you a
right triangle so you have a right angle
because you have an inner product that
is 0 so by Pythagorean theorem okay so
what is this hypotenuse you add these
two vectors and find that this W P Prime
so by Pythagorean theorem we find that
the l2 norm of W P prime equals to the
out to norm of some of the l2 norm
squared of the two legs of this right
triangle
on the other hand this quantity here
okay so let's think about that kanji
over there it's the soup of I mean it's
it's an l2 norm so in particular it has
at least this quantity here which you
can derive in one of many ways for
example by Cauchy Schwarz inequality or
go from l2 to l1 and then pass down to
r1 okay so so this is this is true okay
so let's say by Cauchy Schwarz right so
but this quantity here we said was
bigger than Epsilon so as a result its
final quantity this l2 norm of the new
refinement increases from the previous
one by more than epsilon squared okay so
this is the all true energy increment
argument I claim it's the same argument
basically as the one that we did for
similarities regularity lemma and I
encourage you to go back and compare
them to see why they are the same or
moving on so the other part of
regularity lemma is to iterate this this
approach right so you have something
which is not epsilon regular we find it
and then iterate and you cannot proceed
more than a pound the number of times
because energy is always bounded between
0 and 1 so for every epsilon bigger than
0 and graph on W suppose you have P not
a partition of 0 1 interval into
measurable sets then there exists a
partition P that cuts up each part
Oh peanut into at most four to the one
over epsilon parts such that W minus W
sub P yes at most epsilon so basically
we stating the week regularity lemma
over there but with a small difference
which will become useful later on when
we prove compactness namely I'm allowed
to start with any partition instead of
starting with a trivial partition I can
start with any partition this was also
true when we were talking about some
radius regularity lemma although I
didn't stress that point it's certainly
the case here I mean the proof is
exactly the same with or without this
extra this this place this extra P not
really plays insignificant role what
happens as in the proof of some Randy's
regularity lemma is how we repeatedly
apply the previous lemma to obtain the
sequence of partitions of the zero one
interval where each step either we find
that we obtain some partition P sub I
such that it's a good approximation of W
in which case we stop so or the l2
energy increases by more than epsilon
square and
since the final energy is always at most
one so it's always bounded between 0 and
1 we must stop after at most one over
epsilon square steps and if you
calculate a number of parts each part is
subdivided into at most four parts on
each step which gives you the conclusion
on the final number of parts it's a very
similar to what we did before
all right so that concludes the
discussion of the week regularity lemma
so basically the same proof but weaker
conclusion and better quantitative
balance the next thing and the final
thing I want to discuss today is a new
ingredient which we haven't seen before
and but that will play an important role
in the proof of the compactness in
particular the proof of the existence of
the limit and this is something where I
need to discuss martingales so
martingale is an important object in
probability theory it's a random
sequence ok so wall look at the squeeze
sequences so indexed by non-negative
integers and a martingale is such a
sequence where if I'm interested in the
expectation of the next term and even if
you know all the previous terms so you
have full knowledge of the sequence
before time N and you want to predict on
expectation what the
is then you cannot do better than simply
predicting the last term that you saw
okay so this is the definition of a
martingale you know to to do this
formally I need to talk about
filtrations and whatnot in measure
theory but let me let me not do that and
okay so this is how you think about
martingales and a couple of important
examples are martingales so the first
one is comes from the the reason why
these things are called martingales is
that there is a gambling strategy which
is related to to such a sequence where
let's say you consider a sequence of
fair coin tosses okay so so here's what
we're going to do so suppose we consider
a betting strategy
and X sub n is equal to your balance
time and and suppose that we're looking
at a fair casino where the expectation
of every every game is exactly zero then
this is a martingale right so imagine
you have a sequence of coin flips and
you win $1 for each head and lose $1 for
each tail when you're at time five if
you have no two dollars in your pocket
then at time 5 plus 1 you expect to also
have that many dollars it might go up it
might go down but in expectation it
doesn't change so a question okay so
there's ask but is there some
independence condition required and the
answer's no so there's no independence
condition that is required so the
definition of a martingale is just if
even with complete knowledge of the
sequence up to a certain point the
difference going forward is zero in
expectation so for example okay so
here's another example of a martingale
which actually turns out to be more
relevant to to our use namely that if I
have some hidden think of X as some
hidden random variable okay so something
that you know you have no idea but you
can observe it at time and based on
information up to
time and so for example suppose you have
no idea you know who is going to you
know win the presidential election and
really nobody has any idea but as time
proceeds you make an educated guess
based on the information that you have
all the information you have up to that
point
and that information becomes a larger
and larger set as time moves forward
your prediction there's going to be a
random variable that goes up and down
and that will be a martingale because
like so how I predict today based on you
know what are all the possibilities
happening going forward well one of many
things could happen but if I knew that
my ex my prediction is going to in
expectation shift upwards then I
shouldn't have predicted when I predict
today I should have predicted upwards
anyway okay so this is another
construction of martingales so this also
comes up you know you could have other
you know more pure mathematics type
explanations where suppose I want to
know you know is a what is the chromatic
number of a random graph and I show you
that graph one edge at a time you can
predict the expectation you can find an
expectation of this graph statistic
based on what you've seen up to time N
and that sequence will be a martingale
an important property of a martingale
just known as the martingale convergence
theorem and that's need for the proof of
the existence of the limit next time
set up every bounded martingale so for
example suppose your martingale only
takes values between 0 & 1 so every
bounded martingale converges almost
surely you cannot have a martingale
which you expect to go constantly go up
and down ok so I want to show you a
proof of this fact let me just mention
that the bandit condition is a little
bit stronger than what we actually need
from the proof you see that you really
only need them to be l1 bounded it's
enough and more generally there's a
condition called uniform integrability
which I won't explain all right ok so
let me show you a proof of the
martingale convergence theorem and I'm
going to be somewhat informal somewhat
Cavalier because I don't want to get
into the some of the fine details of
probability theory but you know if you
have taken something like 18 6 5 6 7 5
probability theory then you can fill in
all those details and this proof is so I
like this proof because it's kind of a
proof by gambling so I want to tell you
a story which should convince you that a
martingale cannot keep going up and down
it must converge almost surely so
suppose
xn X sub n doesn't converge and here
okay so this is why I said I'm gonna be
somewhat cavalier with probability
theory so when I say this doesn't
converge I mean a specific instance of
the sequence doesn't converge okay some
specific realization if it doesn't
converge then there exists a and B both
rational numbers between 0 and 1 such
that the sequence crosses the interval a
B infinitely many times so by crossing
this interval and what I mean is the
following
[Applause]
so I have ok so there's an important
picture which will help a lot in
understanding this theorem so imagine I
have this time N and I have a and B so I
have this martingale it's realization
curd okay so that's instance of this
martingale and by crossing I mean a
sequence that ok so here's here's what I
mean by crossing I start below a and so
I start blow a and I go up off B and
then wait until I come back
below a and I call up off B we did until
I come back
so do you like that
so I start below a and how the first
time I go above B and then I stop that
sequence so they are so those are the up
crossings of this martingale up crossing
we start below a and then you end up
above B so if you don't converge then
there exists such a and B so there are
infinitely many such crossings so this
is this is just fact you know it's it's
not hard to see and one more show is
that this doesn't happen except with
probability zero so we'll show that this
occurs with probability zero and because
the only countably many rational numbers
we find that X sub n converges with
probability one okay
so these are up crossings so I didn't
define it but hopefully you understood
from my picture in my description and
let me define by X u sub n to be the
number of up crossings up to time so the
number of such up crossings now let me
consider a betting strategy basically I
want to make money and I want to make
money by following these up crossings
okay so every time you give me a number
and so think of this as the stock market
so it's a fair stock market where you
tell me the price and I get a decide do
I want to buy or don't want to sell so
consider the betting strategy we are at
time at any time we're going to hold
either 0 or 1 share of the stock which
has this moving prices and what we're
going to do is if
xn is less than a it's less than the
lower bound then we're going to buy and
hold
ok so meaning 1 until the first time
that the price reaches above B and then
and then sell as soon as the price as
soon as the first time we see the price
goes above B ok so this is the betting
strategy and it's something which you
can implement if you see a sequence of
prices you can implement this strategy
and this you already hopefully see if
you have many up crossings that each up
crossing you make money each up costing
you make money and this is almost too
good to be true and in fact we see that
the total gain from this strategy like
so if you start with some balance what
do you get at the end is at least
there's difference from a to P times the
number of up crossings okay there's you
might start somewhere you buy and then
you just lose everything so so there's
might be an initial cost and that cost
is bounded because we start with a
bounded martingale I so suppose this is
supposed martingales always between 0 &
1 start with a bounded martingale but on
the other hand there's a theorem about
martingales
which is not hard to deduce from the
definition that no matter what the
betting strategy is the gang and any
particular time must be 0 in expectation
so this is just a property of the
martingale so zero equals to expect a
gain which is at least P minus a times
the expected number of up crossings
minus one and thus the expected number
of up crossings up to time n is at most
one over B minus a now we let and go to
infinity and let u sub infinity be the
total number of up crossings by the
monotone convergence theorem in this
limit by monotone convergence theorem
the limit of these use events it can
never go down it's always no it's always
weakly increasing converges to
expectation of the total number of up
crossings so now in particular you know
that the total number of up crossings is
at most some finite number so in
particular the probability that you have
infinitely many crossings is zero so
with probability 0 you cross infinitely
many times which proves our claim over
there and which concludes the proof of
the claim that the martingale converges
almost shortly ok so that proves the
martingale convergence term so next time
will you combine everything that we did
today to prove the three main terms that
we stated last time on graph limits